I am a K-pop Stan I am a K-pop Stan I am
a K-pop Stan I am a K-pop Stan I am a
K-pop Stan I am a K-pop Stan I am a
K-pop Stan
[Music]
when did everyone get into K-pop and
who's your old groups late 2020 uh stray
kids is my old okay okay I got into it
like around 2018
um and my old group at the moment is
twice okay I started off with black pink
I started around 2020 and I would say
exactly the same line as black pink my
friend started getting me into that I
started liking K-pop in 2015 currently
my my old group is NCT love them I think
for me it was uh 2012. um it was a big
bang and now it's twice like David said
what about you sir um technically 2021
my old groups are MCT and 17. but I got
to Got7 in 2016. I saw them in 2016.
okay and then for me I got it in the
same time as you like 2015 2016 and my
old groups right now are Monsta X and
red velvet yeah
did you see them in concert yeah yeah
have you guys been to any concerts it
was the day of my my graduation I had
college graduation and then right like
an hour later I had
I saw twice three times in one year I I
saw them at the Forum and then I saw
them twice for their Encore
Mina's my bias when she was like when
she was throwing that around I saw I saw
stray kids
eight times within a year just eight
times
what's everyone's ultimate bias does
everyone have an ultimate voice yes
okay yeah oh my God we didn't he just
come back from the military okay okay
mine's just straight up straight kids my
old co-worker tried to like get me to
pick one and I heard it like eyes
watering
if I had to yeah
I can't choose between them and say like
Matthew
I'm a bit suspicious of Faith because it
seems like she's trying to get the
attention off of her and just like keep
switching it
[Applause]
but like there's always that one member
that like attracts you yeah
I've never like never had a bias are you
wait Pablo are you into any like newer
groups
um not really I think I just big bang
like old stuff like hot
Wonder girls and girls Generations
I am pretty suspicious of Pablo Pablo
Pablo he like the older type of K-pop
and wasn't really talking about any new
K-pop stuff and I feel like if you're a
K-pop fan you're kind of going with the
times even though you do like Boulder
stuff do you listen to anything current
I kind of have just that Cupid song but
I'm pretty grandpa in the K-pop no I
have a question do you guys have like
what are terms do you feel like only
like K-pop stands okay yeah
I don't know I just know the acronym i j
Bol I just pressed that laughing
dude I thought it was Korean on my
timeline I was like why are people
speaking in like I didn't know what that
was until just now
I was Korean too I didn't know what nugu
was until like a year into it because I
started working at a K-pop store and
then one of my co-workers was like oh
like what about the new groups I was
like
I was like is that a group
mine was the dungeon dungeon slash
basement and I was like what does that
even mean I was like
oh hey do you ever just love yourself so
much that you just want to sing
I'm gonna stop you right there
how about instead of singing maybe we
can explore that self-love Journey a
little bit further self-love can mean a
lot of different things for everyone
whether it's taking a spa day meditating
but you can find out what self-love
means to you now with 30 off select Lilo
products using Code sing 30 and thank
you to Lilo for redefining what it means
to prioritize your own self-care and for
sponsoring this episode
let's go back to the video
maybe he was someone that like got into
them a long time ago and then he fell
off and now he just like hates K-pop
[Music]
I think because I come off as quiet I
think it's pretty much that and then
especially how was questioned are you
into any like newer groups
qualify me
was everyone's favorite comeback that
has come out this year and team come
back I think is great they're not
capable they're J-pop technically yeah
no so they're in hyphen's brother group
oh okay we were talking about and team
and he was like oh is that a subunit of
and hyphen and I was like I feel like
everyone knows in hyphen so I thought
that was a weird thing to say but that's
my favorite comeback yeah okay yeah I
would say G Idol okay
I was not in the G Idol until Queen card
came out and then I was like let me dive
into their music and I was like okay
wait then the dance because once I
learned those
so the thing is about Kpop stands they
get lost in conversation a lot
especially about like K-pop groups so I
was like okay let's reel it back in come
on let's talk about what we're here for
are you guys all big on merch because
I'm a college student I'm going into my
Master's I don't got money like that
I will say I do spend my money on
concerts even though they are more
expensive when you get there though yeah
yeah it's like the pink logo it's every
five minutes they're updating something
about someone
definitely suspicious of Skyler she
didn't have Twitter
um which is like a really big thing in
the K-pop community and then she didn't
know the name of the like the app that
she did have I even have Facebook I'm
like an old woman on Facebook but not
Twitter Twitter gets so crazy like no
yeah I don't really see anything bad
about Kpop fans and any other social
media
[Music]
David just because he kind of sat back
this round he wasn't really talking much
and I feel like he was just talking
about twice a lot
foreign
she wasn't on Twitter and she only used
um Kpop koreaboo no one really uses that
I don't use Twitter to keep up with
K-pop but I feel like that doesn't make
you a fan if you have an account or not
so if you want to keep playing because
you will still in the box raise your
hand on three
one
two three
that is majority so the new rule is
every wrong person that gets voted out
starting now will deduct from the shared
cash prize okay okay you guys ready yes
okay I have a question yeah did you say
you collect photo cards I do okay do you
know what messes up a photo card like a
PVC okay yeah okay okay okay sorry but
I'm like a little sense of you because
like you've only talked about twice like
do you have any other like groups that
you stay oh yeah like G idle dream catch
okay I like icons music what's your
favorite mama movie besides B-side I
don't know if it's well because like I
listen to them but I don't like I don't
know like I just added like a bunch of
K-pop songs are you only into like title
tracks uh for the most per year like for
other groups I mean I've listened to the
B size but I don't know like the name oh
you know which one I think it's called
um oh my gosh it's like where they're
calling her like short or something yeah
what are things you guys don't like
about K-pop I can go first okay
um the only thing I don't like about
Kpop is what people think of you if you
like Kpop yeah because that's like my
only issue because all of a sudden it's
like oh Korea
listen to like Bad Bunny or like music
in other languages like they don't get
on but I feel like it's like kind of
like people being xenophobic the thing
that I get told the most is like oh how
can you like music that you don't
understand read the lyrics
Like Music isn't just its lyrics like
you're gonna diminish it down to that
then like
I just taught it to my youth class okay
hey
[Music]
oh
yeah
we switched it off oh my gosh
so I was a little bit suspicious of
Sarah right now because she didn't want
to dance not all Kpop fans know the
dances and stuff but you know a thing or
two even if it's like a hand movement
yeah you do like emotions
no I can sticker stickers
it reminds me just of the first one oh
don't be super shy comment below if
you're a K-pop Stan and don't forget to
like And subscribe for more
Hawa because she only knew a couple of
moves
K-pop fans are usually like most times
they're not they're very hyper she's
quiet
actually a tie
a tie Sarah
two minutes you guys can ask them
whatever you want okay you haven't
talked a lot so like is there anything
like you want to like tell us like
specifically I don't want to bring out
the big guns and NCT dream tattoo oh
hello I was like how the hell am I
supposed to freaking prove myself to a
freaking tattoo I couldn't say much I
was just like um I'm into K-pop you can
either believe me or not I love K-pop
man
my friend got me into K-pop shout can I
shout people out shout out sale hey
still She's Gone music
thank you
it's because of the tattoos
I was offended
but then I can understand because again
a tattoo is way too strong to prove
against
one two three
so the game has ended you guys are
confident that the mole has been voted
out if the Box turns red
the mole is still among the four of you
the moles and cash prize for themselves
are you poor ready yes they have three
two
[Music]
one
oh my God
all right I'm gonna count the
mole can step forward okay
everyone ready for the reveal
one two three
you know I was just happy to make it
past the first round to be honest
because I dug really deep in the K-pop
like I even watched a documentary like I
sat through an hour and a half
documentary in pain but that's okay it
did it obviously didn't work so why do
you hate K-pop I feel like the
industry's kind of toxic but I really
hate like the things they do to like the
groups and stuff because there's so many
things that they're banned against
dating eating certain things wearing
certain things and I feel like it's
really hard on people's mental health
like I know moonbin from Astro died in
April from that type of stuff and then
just like the music isn't my time I
really like the Beats like I really like
black pink I feel like after looking at
this and like studying but it's just not
like it's not like a genre I can really
get into I feel like so yeah that's
really cool yeah did you learn any
dances for this I did I sadly did
you thank God no what music do you like
I like r b Indie okay r b is really good
give me some list guys give me some
lists I'll start getting into it but
yeah I came upstairs is somebody who
just has a genuine love for the genre
it's definitely more than just like
knowing the music and the dances and
stuff like that it's definitely being
part of the like K-pop Community I feel
like that's the fun part about Kpop you
make friends so easily yeah
[Music]
let's go